today
私はん
ゴミ掃除の仕事をしています
ゴミはゴミでも普通のゴミとはちょっと違うかもしれません
私が4子をする場所それは宇宙なんです
こちらのシミュレーション映像をご覧下さい
たくさんの点が地球の周りをぐるぐると回っています
このシミュレーション映像は地球のままにある人工衛星やロケットの数を表したもので
この赤い点はもう術今は扱われてないもので
つまりはゴミということです
これらは何かというと
もう使われなくなった人工衛星や
ロケットの一部ロケットは宇宙柄モノを運ぶ役割をしていますがその一部は宇宙に残り
ます
そして爆発など事故が起きて生まれてしまった破片等
私たちが空を見上げてもそんな景色は全く見えません
まさかこの空の向こうがごみだらけなんて想像できるでしょうか
ですが事実この宇宙のゴミ問題が深刻な状況を作り出しているのです
地球を周回する物体は時速78キロで移動しています
これは弾丸よりも早いスピードです
また大きさはというとロケットの一部となると大方はすぐらいの大きさになります
一方でツナ粒のように小さな破片のものまでありますつまり
大小様々な物体が超高速で地球の周りを飛び交っているということになります
さすがにこれだけの数があると
衝突事故ってを着てないのかなって思いませんか
実は起きているんです
2009年アメリカとロシアの衛星が軌道上で衝突事故を起こしています
この衝突によって
1万個以上の宇宙ゴミがまた新たに発生してしまいました
宇宙ごみの脅威とはまさにこのことで
衝突によって生まれた辺がまた別のゴミに衝突してまた新たなハ n を生み出すそう
やってその数がどんどんどんどん増えていくということが問題されているんです
宇宙は遠い存在と燃えているかもしれませんが実は皆さん日常的に宇宙の技術を使って
います
例えば
今日ここへ来るのに gps など
地図アプリを使って来ませんでしたか
そして
朝は勉強も確認してきたのではないでしょうか
ご自宅で bs cs のテレビを見ている方もいらっしゃると思います
これらはすべて人工衛星が可能にしています
また
航空や海上輸送などの骨インフラ
金融取引やビジネスサービス災害監視など私たちの生活の基盤となるところには人工
衛星が支えています
なのでもし万が一宇宙ゴミが衝突してしまったら人工衛星はあっという間に壊れて
しまい今の私たちの便利な生活を維持するのはあっあってとても難しくなってしまい
ます
そんな危機的な状況の中世界中が何もしてこなかったわけでありません
10人以上前から nasa や日本の宇宙機関 jaxa など主要な宇宙機関や
研究機関がこの宇宙ごみの問題にも取り組み始めていますまた国連では国際的な宇宙
ゴミに関する得るを作ろうとしています
ですが世界中が集まってルールを作ろうとすると
政治的な問題
法律の問題お金の問題などなどたくさんの問題が絡んでなかなか前に進まないのです
このような状況の中で民間会社がビジネスとしてやるからこそこの停滞状況を打破
できると考え
宇宙ゴミの掃除をする会社が出来ましたそれが今私が働いている会社です
さて
宇宙のゴミ掃除ビジネスを始めるのに必要なものはなんでしょうか
もちろんまずはお金ですね
そして
次は技術
宇宙ゴミを回収する技術が必要です
みつめビジネスモデルよく誰お金出すんですかって聞かれるんです
そして4つ目が法整備そして最後の5メガ
宇宙のゴミ問題をたくさんの人に知っていただくこと
これが一番重要だと思っています
この課題に取り組むのは
ase パースというチームなんかのコースとポスターズみたいですよねうん
宇宙のゴミ問題は5つの課題を同時に磨いていかなければならず
どれか1つが欠けても成立しませんこの会には経営者からエンジニア晴れ
それ以外にも分野問わず全員が一丸となってこの問題に取り組んでいこうという強い
意志が込められているんです
私はその中で
エンジニアと当時に日本に製造開発拠点があるんですけどそこの代表を務めています
大学から数えて約10年ほど人工衛星の開発に関わってきました
私が主に担当していたのは構造と熱という分野なんですけど
楮というのはロケットに人工衛星を載せたときに打ち上がって言ってその時の浸透とか
荷重に耐えるようにそのボディの設計をするというのがお仕事です
熱というのは宇宙ですと太陽があっパっているのと当たってないところで
100度以上の温度差がありますなのでそんな過酷な温度環境下でも人工衛星の中の
装置やセンサーがちゃーんと服用にほどよい温度に保ってあげるということ
設計をしなければならないっっていうことは
ていました
労組も私が人工衛星に興味を持ったきっかけというのは大学時代なんですけれども
人工衛星はアイデア次第でたくさん度いろんな利用が可能なんだということをしたから
なんです
昨今では面白いことに人工衛星を使って宇宙でエンターテインメントをしようとして
いるところもあります
その中で私は宇宙ゴミビジネスをやりませんかと
今の会社の創業者から声をかけてもらった縁で今ここにいます
私たちは
中ゴミ掃除をするにあたって2段階のアプローチを考えました
1段階目は
もうこれ以上ゴミを増やさないことこれからも人工衛星やロケットがどんどん
打ち上がっていきますそれらがもうこれ以上ゴミにならないようにします
そして2段階目は今あるゴミの数を減らすこと
まあすでにある地球のまわりにあるゴミを回収していくというのが次のステップです
なぜこの二段階にしているかと言うとまず技術的にこの1段階目た二段階目
難易度が異なりますなので段階的なステップアップが必要となります
そして2つめは人工衛星の打ち上げ次長が変化してきたからです
今宇宙業界ではコンステレーションという構想が大変盛り上がりを見せています
コンステレーションとは数百から数千基の衛星を時給前と応用に等間隔に配置をして一
つの役割を果たすものです
このシステムが使えることが可能になると例えば地球上のあらゆるところで
インターネットがつながるようになったり
あらゆる地域で画像や色さまざまな計測データを高頻度に入手することができてそれに
よってたくさんどう多くの産業へのシーンが可能となります
goo
ところで
このようなサービスを展開している2100とか数千基の衛星のうち1機が壊れて
しまったとします
これはもうもちろんゴミということになるんですけれども当然
壊れた衛星と新しい衛星を交換してサービスを継続したいと思いますよね
でもその壊れた衛星が動けないとしたらどうでしょうか
例えばでっか車のようなものを使って移動してあげることが回収してあげることが必要
です
そう例えて言うならこの宇宙ごみ回収サービスというのは車のロードサービスに出ると
思います
壊れた衛星をその場から回収して他の衛星が通る軌道が安全になるように保たれます
また
宇宙ゴミはあのそのまま弾力でも宇宙にとどまり続けるので積極的に回収することで
コメントとゴミの増加を阻止することができます
宇宙のゴミ掃除方法はとってもシンプルで回収して体験に落として思い尽きるという
やり方です
どうやって回収すると思いますか
人が入って回収する
違います
ロボットで回収するちょっと近いんですけれども
なんかガンダムみたいな世界になりますかでも違うんです
私たちは人工衛星でゴミ回収を行います
これは宇宙ごみ回収衛生エルサと言います
宇宙ごみ回収の一連の流れはこうです
まずエルサはロケットによって宇宙まで運ばれますロケットから切り離された後衛星に
搭載したセンサーを駆使してターゲットまでわずか数十センチの距離まで近づきます
地下ついた後
びっくり箱のようなものがニュッと飛び出して相手をつかまえます
この時捕まえるところには磁石が使われています皆さんよくご存知のごく一般的な
尺です
なぜ磁石を使っているか
宇宙は無重力なので相手にとんとしてしまうだけで教育に離れていってしまうんです
その展示作は相手の方から惹きつけられてくるので衛星側で精密なコントロール動きが
入らず
届くに衛星がをのシステムをシンプルにできると考えています
宇宙ゴミをつかまえ回収した後はそのまま
大気圏に突入しても追いつけるという計画です
すごく便利てさあのゴミの分別も不要で全部ホイスきますから
私は宇宙の映画やアニメで描かれたような未来の世界を見てみたいんです
もしかしたらそれはまったく違ったものになっているかもしれませんがそういうことを
考えるととってもワクワクしてきます
きっとそれは多くの産業が宇宙とにして日ついて
また宇宙がより多くの人にとって身近なものになっていると思うんです
これまで宇宙開発というのは国が主導で行ってきました
それを私はみんなのものにしたいと思っています
ただその前に宇宙をきれいにするということが必要なんですね
私たちは
まあこのエルサの試作機を開発中で宇宙で技術実証しようとしています
2020年にロシアのロケットで打ち上げを計画しています
私たちの宇宙ゴミ掃除への取り組みはまだまだ始まったばかりでたくさんのこんなに
使うことでしょう
ですが
何もしないわけにはいけませんなぜなら
地球の周りがこのようにゴミだらけになってしまったのは100%私たち人間の性なん
です
宇宙がこれからも持続的に利用地続けられるよう
宇宙環境を守っていくことが私たちのミッションだと考えています
今日このお話を聞いていただいて宇宙ごみの問題に関心を持っていただけたらとても
嬉しく思いますどうもありがとうございました
[拍手]
[音楽]